we went through very deep dark
difficulties in Lebanon my parents were
kidnapped by fat every single minute of
every day growing up in the Lebanese
Civil War was literally had the
potential of being the last day if
someone knocked at your door there was a
very very good chance that this was
going to be the end of you death awaited
me every second of every day and so that
could have sent me into a psychiatric
Institute it could have turned me into a
drug addicted guy it actually did the
opposite to me at the end of the night I
say tomorrow is a new day I'm going to
live a dignified life I'm going to live
a meaningful life my life is going to
matter I'm going to hopefully affect
positive change and that will be my best
revenge